baba gens de la lune et dans l'allée
jean de la lune s'ennuyait tout seul là
aux ajouts il décida d'aller visiter la
terre mais très cher sujet la terre
toute entière a été conquise une attaque
provenant d'une étoile a tenu à les
rattraper les suivait les traces de pas
capturer moi c'est trouillarde
envahisseurs
il est parti qui est parti j'en ai mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça goethe
examine de la tête aux pieds sans même
te demander d'où tu viens des lives les
enfants prétend que jean de la lune mais
plus chez lui et que par conséquent il
ne veuille plus sur eux je dois vraiment
tout faire moi même
vous restez où vous êtes punis
la terre est sauvé j'ai mille dangereux
envahisseurs derrière les barreaux ait
besoin de la lune nous manque
jean de la lune cette échappée rattraper
le fuyard
pouvez-vous me ramener chez moi sur la
lune la lune est ma maison je veux être
là pour tous les gens de la terre